un européen consomme chaque année 1 9
million de litres d'eau c'est
l'équivalent de la moitié d'une piscine
olympique on va voir ce qui se cache
derrière cette consommation
[Musique]
depuis la fin du 19e siècle la
consommation d'eau domestique des
français a été multipliée par dix voici
5 astuces pour lutter contre cet immense
gâchis
combien d'actions c'est dans les
toilettes que ça se passe dans le
réservoir il suffit de glisser une
bouteille d'un litre et demi qui
permettra de faire autant d'économies à
chaque fois que vous tirez la chasse
puisque cette bouteille occupe désormais
le réservoir
ça peut paraître anodin mais c'est
jusqu'à 3000 litres d'eau par an et par
personne d'économies pendant qu'on est
dans la salle demain notre geste
d'importance et de préférer la douche
plutôt que le bain ou une douche de
moins de 3 minutes permet de diviser par
10 sa consommation d'eau un autre geste
pour faire des économies d'eau chez soi
c'est d'installer un mousseur sous ses
robinets ce qui permet d'aérer l'eau et
de faire jusqu'à 50% d'économies donc
vous voyez on a ici le débit d'eau
classique on voit l'eau couler et on
peut installer cette petite pièce de
métal qui se retrouve chez n'importe
quel magasin de bricolage pour quelques
euros à peine c'est très simple à
installer le pas de vis et standard il
suffit de visser en dessous du robinet
ça prend absolument 5 secondes et
regarder l'ol a blanchi ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui elle est aérée et donc il
ya moins de volume d'eau une autre
astuce c'est de faire la vaisselle à
l'ancienne ça veut dire qu'on symbole
sans quasiment utiliser d'eau du coup un
tout petit filet d'eau pour un c
[Applaudissements]
et voilà une vaisselle fait avec moins
d'un litre d'eau dernière astuce ont
fait la traque aux fido chez soi un
robinet qui goutte c'est 100 litres
d'eau de gaspiller par jour soit au
total 100 euros de gâcher chaque année
et une chasse d'eau qui fuit ça peut
même être jusqu'à 600 litres d'eau
gaspillée chaque jour soit au total plus
de 800 euros
gaspiller tous les ans un autre chose à
laquelle on pense pas forcément quand on
parle de consommation d'eau c'est notre
consommation de bouteilles en plastique
pour une bouteille d'un demi litre on a
besoin en fait de trois litres d'eau et
de 33 centilitres de pétrole pour mettre
enfin un terme à tous ces déchets on
consomme de l'eau du robinet et nous on
va aller justement voir ce qui se passe
derrière notre robinet c'est là bonjour
merci de nous accueillir ici tu es
adjointe à la maire de paris à la
transition écologique et moi la première
question que je me posais c'est qu'est
ce qui se passe quand on tourne notre
robinet il se passe plein de choses
derrière robin et on se rend pas compte
mais derrière les robinets à paris à 90
métier 900 femmes et hommes qui bossent
tous les
pour amener l'eau à paris et notamment
ont déclenché dans une installation
comme celle là on est au réservoir de
montsouris dans le 14e arrondissement et
on stocke ici une grande partie de l'eau
potable des parisiens donc parti
derrière le robinet qui se joue ici tu
ne montres avec plaisir on y va allons-y
[Musique]
ça y est c'est là on arrive aux fameuses
cube entourent là on a des centaines de
mètres de couloirs un qui entourent
vraiment tous les bassins pour savoir ce
qu'on est vraiment sûr on se passe de
trois hectares en tout cas c'est très
très animaux qui monte qui baisse au fur
et à mesure de la journée
les fiona tant que bonne soir ouvrez
açores four pour le remplir maintenant
pour faire qu'on a toujours cette
capacité en fait des avances et de marge
de sécurité
donc là c'est là on est sur le toit du
réservoir
oui il paraît que c'est une grande
prairie un grand terrain de foot mais en
fait on est effectivement sur le toit du
plus grand réservoir de paris ça c'est
vraiment les grands aménagements
d'haussmann des belles grand à un moment
il fallait apporter de l'eau aux
parisiens ils font des aménagements
titanesque en quelques années dont la
création de grand aqueduc 150 km qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on produit en tribu
chaque jour 500 mille mètres cubes d'eau
tous les jours à paris
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on est là c'est bien mais
voilà
la rentrée
et une hausse du coût qui est propulsé
et qui arrivent dans des aqueducs tu
disais d aqueduc qui viennent de
plusieurs régions autour de paris
il ya pas mal d'idées reçues qui
circulent autour de l'eau
comme quoi l'eau potable ne serait pas
aussi potable que ce qu'ont bien dit
r avec pas mal de choses
qui sont nocives à la consommation est
ce que c'est vraiment le cas
les wallons
l'eau est effectivement menacée sur le
long terme y compris en france et elle
est menacé à deux titres on va avoir osé
sous les effets du dérèglement
climatique un problème de quantité d'eau
on sait d'ores et déjà que d'un an après
hâtive que nos fleuves vont perdre de
l'eau et ce problème de quantité
exacerbé les problèmes de qualité de
l'eau moyen d'occuper les pollutions se
concentraient donc il faut faire des
économies et il faut clairement changer
nos modes de vie pour soi moins polluant
que ce soient les modes agricole mais le
mode aussi à de j
déchets de consommation pour protéger
cette fois c'est un gros challenge
métiers majeurs faut le répéter quand
même encore une fois l'eau est vitale a
tous besoin pour vivre
quand tu n'auras plus haut risque d'être
vraie bombe et et célia merci beaucoup
pour la visite alors là on vient de voir
un toute l'eau qui a derrière notre
robinet mais il faut savoir que 96 %
notre consommation en eau est invisible
sato elle est cachée où elle est cachée
dans l'agriculture qui est responsable
de 70% de la consommation de l'eau dans
le monde
il faut savoir que pour faire un kilo de
chocolat on a besoin de dix sept mille
litres d'eau un kilo de café ses seize
mille litres d'eau et un kilo de viande
bovine ses 15 litres d'eau quelques
conseils adoptez une alimentation plutôt
flexitariens nous voir végétarienne et
manger local et de saison pour les
vêtements qui représentent quand même 4
% de l'eau consommée dans le monde m'a
privilégié tout simplement des vêtements
faits en fibres recyclées et même
idéalement acheter tout en seconde main
changer son monde c'est changer le monde
et participer à la construction d'un
monde meilleur ça commence par mois
[Musique]